bootlegate podcast with Phoenix Arizona
for the Super Bowl shout out to Def Jam
shout out to LRG shout out to Remy
Martin we about to have my guy Chris
Coke tear this [__] down one time let's
go
yeah yeah
ho
yeah
Super Bowl weekend bullet cat podcast
shout out Remy Martin LRG
Def Jam
yeah
let me show you how a Mexican dude
ah nightmare I do this day by day three
bodies for ten thousand same game parlay
like Christian being wild and try and
pay my way and Jersey is three thousand
call it zip Andre you hit my yay got you
feeling like you Tony now anytime I did
it I done it wasn't no homie's round
flame on me don't aim on me if [__] fail
shots don't you try and dream on me I
don't know you dog you can get some
flame on me [__] knife Nina nuclear I
bring all three I'm from the West Coast
red Chucks don't bang on me I promise
the way you coming ain't the way y'all
leave you ain't gotta hit poppy call me
for the brick face and get lace it's the
ball game we pitch bases sip Ace bodies
get misplaced clean rental car switch
Place dismissed case the [__] straight
tell the truth is you a factual shooter
I'm not in tune with the streets they're
not exactly Shooters pulling drastic
Maneuvers attack with a Mac and a ruler
if you ever need a lesson I'll be happy
to school you the murder course but the
energy is free and the Super Bowl
winning ball celebrities to me usually
looking for a lick but the Hennessy and
me said Rob the first kid with the
rollie on freeze yeah the wig clappers
the real kidnapping knowing that you
meeting God if they send Chris at you
defensive line drama man they can't get
past this anybody wants smoke get turned
to their asses yeah oh it's like dummy
is you serious cleanest 40s and look out
since the NFL experience the room full
watch out Chris Cole get the clearance
[__] came to AZ thought it was sweet up
the appearances you about to get burned
just like ribs at the cookout at the
dice game take off or you get took out
it's Phoenix best shooter you ain't
gotta bring book out but look out
heading anywhere don't take the hood
around facts and I advise you pay the
kid to lose your [__] right to the game
like Tom Brady did you got robbed in the
desert know it hurts like Jalen
understand I sent someone to every
church that I came in red flag with the
birds I'll be banging meet you with this
50 then you might meet Canaan yeah
foreign
hey what up y'all appreciate you guys
watching this week's freestyle we're
dropping another one next week and
sometimes we drop more than one in a
week but they're always brought to you
by LRG baby that's right loving me some
LRG always and right now if you go to
the website L Dash R Dash g.com and you
use the promo code bootleg you're gonna
get 30 off 30 off that's almost half
at checkout that's right all right shout
out to LRG one more time L Dash R Dash
g.com and when you check out use that
promo code bootleg and save 30 off the
freestyles we'll be back next week
always brought to you by LRG baby